c'est une première une triste première
dans un zoo européen un rhinocéros du
parc de thoiry a été découvert tué par
balles ce matin une de ses cornes
sectionné l'animal âgé de 5 ans présente
plusieurs impacts à la tête l'une de ses
défenses a été découpé à la tronçonneuse
les gendarmes de la brigade de
recherches de mantes-la-jolie sont en
charge de l'enquêté
les salariés sont sous le choc le parc a
toujours été mobilisés contre ce trafic
il avait organisé une grande conférence
sur ce thème en 2013
le braconnage qui occupe la quatrième
place dans le classement mondial des
marchés criminels derrière la drogue la
cybercriminalité ou encore à la traite
des êtres humains
une corne de rhinocéros se monnaye
jusqu'à 40000 euros
c'est très très très choquant parce que
là tout tous nos confrères et tous sont
terriblement choqué que c'est pu arriver
dans un parc zoologique on part quand
même du principe que les animaux qui
sont dans un parc zoologique son protégé
justement du braconnage qu'on rencontre
dans la nature donc là c'est très très
choquant